no it's uh international transgender day
of visibility and you know the white
house was good enough to invite me here
and uh be visible i suppose uh and i'm
just really really honored to be here
and really grateful
um that this is being celebrated and
then the trans people are being
celebrated uh in in a place like this
what are you hoping your visit to the
white house uh accomplishes today i
think just the same thing that i've been
accomplishing which is just again being
a trans person out there that isn't
monstrous and isn't threatening and is
just a normal person like we all are um
so the more that people like me can be
seen the harder it is to sustain the the
myths that are that are kind of driving
a lot of this this hate and fear do you
want to comment on the bills proceed
around
uh they're really scary and
some of them in particular that are
denying medical services uh to trans
youth
those are those are life-saving medical
treatments and they will you know these
bills
will cause the deaths of children
and that's really sad to me and it's
really frightening what's your message
to students living in those states
um
hang in there i don't think that this is
uh i think that this backlash right now
is temporary i think that
this you know that the country overall
is on our side and getting more so every
day and i think it's not going to be too
long before these sorts of bills are
seen as a thing of the past and no
longer what we want to be as a country
you